وكما يقول المصريون الحياه اصبحت على كف
عفريت انتخابات الرئاسيه لدوله تقام على
اراضي دوله اخرى حرب مئه عام جديده يسطرها
التاريخ المعاصر صراع طويل الامد عمره قرن
من الزمان جارتا وحليفه الامس تتحولان الى
الذ الاعداء اليوم الاف القتلى يتساقطون
كل فتره وهدنه هشه تحول الصراع الى نار
تحت رماد قد تشتعل في اي وقت وها هي قد
اشتعلت ما هي جذور الصراع بين اذربيجان
وارمينيا وما هي القنبله الموقوته التي
وضعتها روسيا بين الدولتين ولماذا تفجرت
الحرب بينهما اليوم مره اخرى وما هي
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي استفزت بها
ارمينيا جارتها وكيف تحاول تركيا استغلال
الموقف لصالحها وكيف نجح الدب الروسي في
هذه الساحه التي فشل فيها
لتعرف اجابه كل تلك الاسئله تابع الفيديو
للنهايه قنبله روسيه موقوده ترجع جذور هذا
الصراع الى عام
1923 عندما اعطت روسيا اقليم ناغورني
كاراباخ الواقع بين دولتي اذربيجان
وارمينيا رسميا الى اذربيجان كان الاقليم
يسكنه اقليه مسيحيه او بمعنى ادق رعايه
ارمان هنا شعرت ارمينيا ان جزءا من
جغرافيتها وشعبها قد سلبوا منها عنوه ولكن
في ظل وجود الاتحاد السوفيتي كل شيء لابد
من ان يبقى هادئا
اشتعال الازمه بعض انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي رات ارمينيا ان المناخ قد اصبح
مناسبا للتحرك ففي عام 92 تم اعلان اقليم
كاراباخ جمهوريه مستقله الحرب تندلع مع
اذربيجان 30 يسقطون على الارض كاوراق
الخريف ويتم نزوح اكثر من مليون مواطن من
الاقليم ليواجه مصيرا مجهولا كل هذا دون
الوصول الى حل مرض للطرفين ارمينيا تتراجع
بعد الخسائر الفادحه لكنها تعيد الكره
مرارا النزاع يهدا ويشتعل يهدا ويشتعل
لياتي عام 2020 ويتم التوصل الى هدنه بين
البلدين بواسطه بوتين ولكنها كانت هدنه
هشه وكلا الطرفين كان يحضر نفسه الاستئناف
الحرب مره اخرى وهو ما حدث اليوم
انفجار البركان
ظلت الاوضاع هادئه بين العدوتين اللدودتين
منذ الهدنه الاخيره فلا احد يريد المغامره
باغضاب الدب الروسي ولكن مع انشغال بوتين
في حرفه ضد الغرب بدات ارمينيا تحرك من
جديد ففي التسع من سبتمبر الجاري دعمت
ارمينيا انتخابات رئاسيه اقامها
الانفصاليون
تمهيدا لاعلانه جمهوريه مستقله ولم تمر
ايام قليله لتستيقظ اذربيجان على انفجار
لغمين راح ضحيته اثنان من المدنيين واربعه
من رجال الشرطه ليقوم الجيش الاذري بقصف
الانفصاليين باقليم كراباخ تحت عنوان
الحرب على الارهاب ويسيطر على عشرات
المعاقل التابعه للانفصاليين في الاقليم
الملتهب وها هي لا تكتفي بالوقوف
دبلوماسيا بجانب اذربيجان بل اعلنت انقر
علنا لصديقتها دون خجل نحن معكم حتى
النهايه فقد دخل التركي على خط الازمه
ودعمت الجيش بعدد من طائره برقدار التركيه
التي ساهمت في قصف الانفصاليين الارمن سقط
ضحيه القصف اكثر من 100 قتيل ومئات الجرح
حتى الان ناهيك عن هروب الالاف من منازلهم
خوفا من ان تهدم على رؤوسهم
الاستسلام قبل الكلام
حاولت امريكا تدخل وانهاء حاله الحرب ولكن
الرئيس الاثري الهام علياف ابلغ وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
قائلا هم من اعتدوا اولا لا وقف لاطلاق
النار الا بعد استسلام الانفصاليين الارمن
وتسليمهم اسلحتهم لن نتحدث معهم الا وهم
منزوع السلاح وفي الوقت الذي فشل فيه العم
وسام في انهاء الازمه كان مفتاح الحل في
يد الدب الروسي فما الذي حدث
نهايه الحرب
تدخلت قوات حفظ السلام الروسي الموجوده
بالمنطقه واجبرت الانفصاليين الارمن على
تسليم سلاحهم والموافقه على شروط اذربيجان
واعلان وقف اطلاق النار على ان يتم الجلوس
على طاوله المفاوضات في اليوم التالي من
اجل اعاده دمج اقليم كرافخه مجددا في
اذربيجان وانهاء هذا النزاع طويل الامد نج
ح الدب الروسي في انهاء المعركه القائمه
حاليا ولكن يبدو ان انهاء الحرب كلها شيء
اخر السؤال الان لكم مشاهدينا هل انهى
التدخل الروسي النزاع بين ارمينيا
واذربيجان الى الابد ام ان النار ستظل
مشتعله تحت الرماد وكلا البلدين سيعيد
ترتيب اوراقه لمعاوده الهجوم على عدوه مره
اخرى اخبرونا في صندوق التع